AstraZeneca may be able to help.
>> PHASE FOUR.
WE SHOULD HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A
PAYROLL TAX MORATORIUM.
I MEAN, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE -- I’M ONE OF THEM --
THAT WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE
SEEN THE PAYROLL TAX CUT AS A
PERMANENT CUT.
BUT WE SHOULD DO THE DOUBLE
EDGED -- MEANING BUSINESS,
EMPLOYEE PAYROLL TAX CUT.
SO WE’RE TALKING ABOUT THAT.
PETE: THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TALKING ABOUT THE NEXT PHASE OF
OPENING UP OUR ECONOMY, WHICH IS
READY TO GO WHEN WE ARE READY TO
LET IT GO.
HERE TO REACT TO THAT
REPRESENTATIVE BRAD WENSTRUP,
BUCK FROM OHIO, MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
AND A PHYSICIAN, ALSO AN IRAQ
WAR VET HIMSELF.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE THIS MORNING.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
SO WHAT IS THE FEEL ON CAPITOL
HILL ABOUT WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN
NEXT?
YOU HAVE GOT TO PASS THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE.
THE PRESIDENT CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
HE WANTS.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN?
>> YEAH, I THINK THERE ARE
DEFINITELY SOME THINGS THAT WE
WANT TO DO FURTHER.
WE HAVE DONE THREE PHASES OF
ASSISTANCE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND TO THE WHOLE FIGHT AGAINST
THIS PANDEMIC AS IT IS.
IN MANY WAYS, I WANT TO SEE THE
FIRST THREE PHASES ROLL OUT
SUCCESSFUL AND SEE WHERE WE ARE
WITH THAT.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT, FOR
EXAMPLE, WITH THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM WE WANT TO
GET MORE TO IT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED FOR THAT
AND WE WANT TO DO IT.
YOU KNOW, IT’S BEEN A LITTLE
CHALLENGING, OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE
WE ARE ALL WORKING FROM AFAR,
BUT WE ARE WORKING.
AND WE ARE TRYING TO GET
SOMETHING DONE.
WE WILL BE GLAD TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DO WHAT’S
BEST FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
GET THROUGH THIS AND THEN GET
OUR COUNTRY BACK ON TRACK.
PETE: WHAT’S MOST LIKELY TO
PASS?
NANCY PELOSI HAS BEEN ON
STINNETT.
ON ON
OBSTINATE.
WHEN IT COMES TO STAYING FOCUSED
ON SMALL BUSINESS, CAN THAT
HAPPEN?
DO YOU HAVE GOOD FAITH PARTNERS
ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, THAT’S THE CHALLENGE,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE I DON’T THINK WE REALLY
DID, ESPECIALLY IN PHASE THREE
OF THIS WHOLE PROCESS BECAUSE
THEY WERE HOLDINGS THINGS OUT.
DELAYING THE WHOLE PROCESS JUST
FOR A FEW ITEMS.
NOTHING IS MORE GLARING THAN THE
25 MILLION THAT WENT TO THE
KENNEDY CENTER.
AND I SAID UNLESS THE KENNEDY
CENTER IS BEING SET UP AS A
MAKESHIFT HOSPITAL FOR
CORONAVIRUS, THIS HAS NO PLAY
HERE.
BUT, I THINK MS. PELOSI WILL TRY
TO GET THINGS IN.
AND WE WILL SEE IF WE CAN STOP
HER.
I HOPE WE CAN THERE ARE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO GET DONE IN
ORDER TO GET THROUGH.
THIS THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDS
THAT SO, HOPEFULLY, WE WON’T SEE
FURTHER DELAYS FROM MS. PELOSI.
LET’S STICK TO WHAT THE PROBLEM
IS AT HAND AND GET AID INTO THE
HANDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
SO THAT SMALL BUSINESSES, AS YOU
MENTIONED.
CAN MAINTAIN THEMSELVES, NOT
LOSE EMPLOYEES.
THE KEY.
WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO PAY
THEIR BILLS.
DON’T LOSE EMPLOYEES AND DRIVE
ON.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, YOU TALK
ABOUT PROBLEMS.
LET ME TAKE TO YOU A DIFFERENT
ONE.
THAT IS THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
DR. TEDROS WAITS UNTIL
MARCH 11TH TO DECLARE IT A WORLD
PANDEMIC IN WHICH 2,000 PEOPLE
HAVE DIED.
114,000 CASES IN 14 COUNTRIES.
HE EVEN HAS THE GULL TO PAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO EARLIER IN
FEBRUARY STOPPED FLIGHTS FROM
CHINA WHICH WE NOW KNOW HAS
SAVED COUNTLESS LIVES.
IS IT TIME TO CUT FUNDING TO
W.H.O.?
>> WELL, I THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS DOING THE RIGHT THING IN
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS
TO BE THERE TO BE TRANSPARENT SO
THAT WE HAVE FACTS AND WE KNOW
WHAT IS GOING ON.
I SERVED ON OUR BOARD OF HEALTH
IN CINCINNATI.
YOU CANNOT PROCEED WITH TAKING
CARE OF HEALTHCARE ISSUES IF YOU
DON’T HAVE THE FACTS.
IF YOU ARE TWISTING THE FACTS.
IF YOU ARE IN DENIAL ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING ON, THAT’S A
PROBLEM.
AND WHAT’S CURIOUS, I AND SOME
OF MY MEDICAL COLLEAGUES HAVE
DONE A LOT OF RESEARCH ON
EVERYTHING THAT’S TAKEN PLACE,
WHAT’S BEING DONE IN CHINA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MEDICAL
RESEARCH.
YOU CAN TELL THAT THEY KNEW
SOMETHING BIG WAS GOING ON
EARLIER THAN THEY HAVE EVER
ADMITTED TO.
SO, ON THE MEDICAL SIDE, IT
SEEMS THAT THERE WAS SOME
TRANSPARENCY BUT ON THE
POLITICAL SIDE AND ON THE
GOVERNMENT SIDE, OBVIOUSLY NOT.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE CONNECTION
TRYING TO PLAY THIS DOWN.
YOU SAW THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY SPEAK OUT
AT ONE POINT AND SAY THEY DIDN’T
WANT A TRAVEL BAN.
WHY DO YOU THAT?
THE NUMBERS, YOU KNOW, HAVE TO
BE REAL.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT’S
GOING ON IF THE UNITED STATES
AND THE REST OF THE WORLD ARE
GOING TO RESPOND APPROPRIATELY.
SO, FROM HERE ON OUT, I THINK,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE ACTING ON OUR
OWN.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC OURSELVES AND OUR
MEDICAL COMMUNITY ALONG WITH OUR
GOVERNMENT IS DOING A GREAT JOB.
I THINK OF THAT BUT, BOY, THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN A WHOLE LOT
WORSE HAD THE PRESIDENT NOT
ACTED.
AND I THINK THAT THE W.H.O. HAS
A LOT OF EXPLAINING TO DO.
I KNOW THIS PRESIDENT WILL PRESS
ON THAT AND WE AS MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS SHOULD, TOO.
JILLIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
>> IT’S GOT TO BE AN OPEN AND
HONEST OR WE WILL FAIL.
JILLIAN: AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
HONEST AND TRANSPARENT ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THAT YOU MENTION.
LET’S TALK ABOUT PLASMA.
BLOOD BANKS ARE PLEADING THAT
THEY NEED DONATIONS.
PLASMA FROM RECOVERED PATIENTS.
WE WERE TALKING TO DR. NICOLE
SAPHIER THIS MORNING ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THE PLASMA IS GOING TO
BE IN ADDITION TO THOSE ANTIBODY
TESTS.
SO WHERE ARE WE WITH THAT RIGHT
NOW?
>> I THINK IT’S MOVING RIGHT
ALONG.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE ARE GOING
TO NEED DONORS, RIGHT?
AND I THINK DR. SAPHIER, BY THE
WAY DID, A PHENOMENAL JOB
EXPLAINING THAT TODAY.
THIS IS ONE WAY OF FINDING OUT
IF PEOPLE HAVE THE VIRUS AND GOT
BETTER.
SO THAT’S GOING TO BE PEACE OF
MIND FOR THEM.
THEY CAN RETURN TO THE
WORKFORCE.
BUT I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT IT’S
IMPORTANT THAT WE REACH OUT TO
OUR PHYSICIANS.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS WE
ARE DOING, TRYING TO DO THROUGH
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS,
OUR PHYSICIANS THAT ARE TREATING
COVID PATIENTS HAVE TO BE AWARE
OF WHERE PATIENTS ARE IN THE
PROCESS THAT WOULD MAKE THEM
ELIGIBLE TO BE GOOD DONORS.
AND PEOPLE THAT THEY THINK THEY
HAVE HAD IT OR KNOW THEY HAVE
HAD IT, NEED TO BE ABLE TO REACH
OUT TO THEIR BLOOD BANK THROUGH
THEIR PHYSICIAN AND GO AND HAVE
THE PLASMA DONATED.
THIS IS A HUGE THING.
CAN I TELL YOU THREE WEEKS AGO,
TALKING TO MY MEDICAL COLLEAGUES
SAYING IF WE HAD 55-GALLON DRUMS
FULL OF IGG, THAT’S THE ANTIBODY
THAT YOU NEED, WE COULD SAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN GET TO
PEOPLE BEFORE THEY NEAT A
VENTILATOR.
JILLIAN: I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WOULD STEP UP AND WANT TO DONATE
THEIR PLASMA IF THEY KNEW THEY
WERE ABLE TO.
>> THAT’S AMERICA, RIGHT?
AMERICA STEPPING UP TO PROBLEMS.
OUR PEOPLE ARE GREAT.
AND THEY JUST NEED TO HAVE THE
AWARENESS OF THANK YOU FOR
PUSHING IT OUT THIS MORNING.
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PUSH IT OUT.
BECAUSE IT’S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
IF WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED.
AND WE WILL SAVE A LOT OF LIVES
WITH THIS AS WELL.
I’M CONVINCED.
PETE: GOOD STUFF.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.